I find women's underwear to be pretty
uncomfortable so I want to see what the
guys got look like this is really gonna
open me up to what men feel like I can't
imagine it's comfortable I think I could
do a good job of imagining having a
penis important and then I'm I'm gonna
understand the other sex better now yeah
this is weird
we're so high I don't know why they're
so remembers this how'd you like to take
it
actually I don't know do you have to use
it as a snake you sneaking around the
first letter for Pete you use this pee
hole or do you just take the whole thing
off Oh guys not pull your underwear down
when they pee I've never seen a boy
piece
it is a flap yeah we're done
this one is a pullout just whip them out
on people that's what this one's for
step four like the tennis ball like
pattern that's right here which i think
is kind of strange
so just like confuse because it's like
what shape is this what your dick is a
baseball I love me for like a minute two
areas I think they're adorable first of
all but you got put pants over these
yeah there's just so much happening
those like too many layers too many pee
putting pants over pants
dudes are afraid of a situation where
they can't get their dick out fast
enough and they're like quick pull it
out this way different suits me like
boxers and briefs and boxer briefs is
like minuscule if you're not wearing a
thong I don't want to hear about it I
see that guys are reorganizing so much
you know there's a lot happening that we
don't necessarily know about they're
wearing boxers just give them a pass
like guys really there's just so much
fabric here it's just confusing
it's like on a airplane like it's come
here dear come out of the way